it's great to be joined today by Stephen
Pearlstein who's a Business and
Economics columnist at the Washington
Post he's also Robinson professor of
public affairs at George Mason
University in Fairfax Virginia his
recent book is called Ken American
capitalism survive why greed is not good
opportunity is not equal and fairness
won't make us poor a Stephen thanks so
much for talking to me today
my pleasure the book relates to so much
of what we've been talking about on our
program and so many of the sort of
fundamental economic questions that are
increasingly being discussed about the
failings and successes of capitalism
social democracy other economic systems
so maybe you can start just by kind of
big picturing it for us what are the
fundamental problems that you see with
the economic system we currently have in
the United States well as you know a lot
of young people and even not so young
people are sort of down on capitalism
these days and they express some support
for something else they call it
socialism I'm not sure they know exactly
what they mean by socialism but in any
case there's a feeling that our system
is is not it's not acceptable and some
of that has to do with the economics of
it that we have an economy that although
it's booming and has you know been
growing fairly well for a while with
some interludes has left a lot of people
behind and so some of the anxiety is is
economic and we know about that but I'd
say even probably even more is that we
have a sense that our system has run off
the moral rails that it's lost its moral
legitimacy that it routinely offends our
moral sensibilities and for the last
thirty years we've been told by people
who I might call market fundamentalists
that we should ignore our moral
instincts we should ignore these
feelings that something's not fair or
something's not right and simply focus
on the fact that
what matters is growth and GDP and if
you try to do anything about those moral
instincts and repulsions that we have
that we're going to we're going to kill
the goose that lays the egg and so what
I tried to do in this book is go back to
a set of ideas which are lay behind this
this notion of ignore your Moral
Sentiments and and it really examined
them and find that they basically while
there's a German truth in them that they
don't actually hold up to scrutiny yeah
I'd love to talk a little bit about the
origins of the idea that growth is
something to be desired indefinitely and
even something that is used as a sort of
yardstick because if we think back to
hunter-gatherer societies or even early
agricultural societies which were
basically looking to create enough food
for themselves to survive sort of a
subsistence approach the idea of growth
was only necessary to track the growth
of the population and to sort of make
sure you had enough food for people
right so at what point that the idea of
growth for the sake of growth becomes
something seen as the goal a good thing
a virtuous thing I'm not sure I can
answer that question David I mean people
you know they Linda's for most of
history most of people lived a
subsistence existence and it was only
during at the point of the Industrial
Revolution that people began to see that
they could actually live much better
lives in terms of what they had that not
only the food they had but the health
and the housing and the clothing and the
the other parts of life that could be
improved and we've we've in general been
on an upward trend ever since ever since
then in the industrial world and I think
we I think we can pretty much all agree
that that having rising standard of
living is a good thing and the way we
had in general have got rising standard
of living is that the pie has grown and
as the pie grows each of our slice of
the pie grows they may grow a little
on equally but some because there is
some growth all of us do better today
than we did before or that our parents
did before and that has been pretty much
the American story since since people
landed on these shores
so I'll get sort of my economic views
out there just so the audience is kind
of reminded of them and you you know
what where I sort of M I find that a lot
of the language you use such as there's
a sort of germ of truth in many of the
talking points but you need to
contextualize them or we need to have
competition but it needs to be
controlled competition basically that
all gets me to social democracy i I
think that having private ownership of
businesses is okay I am NOT for
Stalinist communism and government
ownership of industry but I think that
those germs of truth have been allowed
to sort of fester unmitigated
uncontrolled in a way that has become
destructive that's sort of my view on
the germs of truth from capitalism's
talking points can you give me sort of
your perspective on that well that's my
my perspective too and we'll have to
explore whether we agree about all the
details of it but let's take one idea
yeah which is that greed is good you
know that started out as something of a
joke in a movie but in fact it did
become the sort of rallying cry for a
generation in the 1980s and it has
becomes this sort of symbolic way that a
lot of critics think of American
capitalism today now of course there's a
there's a germ of truth that I'm sure
you understand and most people
understand that a market system depends
on on ambition and self-interest
everyone trying in his own or her own
way to improve his own standing his own
welfare and what he has what the income
is and if everyone does that in a sort
of selfish way as Adam Smith reminded us
then in fact not only as each individual
better off but all individuals have
better
and the economy is better off in the
society is better off that's the
invisible hand we are led as if by an
invisible hand to a better place well
that's true but you know you can take
that sort of thing so far and Adam Smith
also said in another book the Theory of
Moral Sentiments that in fact you have
to do that in a context where people
treat each other fairly in which the the
fruits of everyone's labor is divided
not only according to you know their
contribution but somewhat fairly so that
nobody is living in poverty that people
need to trust each other and not behave
in a ruthless manner because if you do
if you do behave in a ruthless manner
then the system doesn't work so well and
that we all have a natural instinct in
fact not only to do well but to be
respected and to be liked and you have
to behave in a certain way and or in
order to be perspective and to be liked
so it's a sort of nuanced thing yes we
also we all have a selfish gene but we
all have the cooperative gene we all
have an empathetic gene and they they
compete with each other to control our
behavior and if any one or the other
gets out of hand then our economic
system doesn't work too well
yeah what's interesting about greed is
good to stick with that one for a little
bit since since it's a good one you we
seem to have there's a lot of
polarization in general when we talk
about politics economics etc but in this
particular case I'm talking about
polarization that leads people to one of
two extremes one is humans are greedy
and therefore the correct system is one
where humans are just allowed to be as
greedy as they want to be they're
allowed to take as much as they are able
to take based on force or whatever else
the other side of that can sometimes be
greed is so bad that we need the
government to take over industry to
prevent that greed from playing any role
and it seems so obvious to me that the
the path that benefits the most people
in the greatest way is let's first of
all instead of calling it greed let's
consider it humans
interest and let's create a system that
allows the positive sides of ambition
and self-interest to manifest while
ensuring that nobody is getting left
behind
that middle path seems to me to be the
one that is almost like evolutionarily
logical but politically speaking you
don't really hear about it as much as
some of the extremes no you don't and it
is a malucia nary required because as a
species
the reason we're at the top of the food
chain is because more than any other
species although others do too we learn
to cooperate right and that allows us we
started out cooperating as a family unit
protect our children then we became
tribal and if we cooperated within the
tribe we survived and maybe we killed or
at least we were protected from other
tribes and then we widen the circle more
and more and the more we widen the
circle of cooperation the better we did
as a species and and the better
countries do when they when they are
cooperative when when people do trust
each other and capitalism requires that
democracy requires that and we believe
we've lost we've lost I think everyone
agrees a level of trust and cooperation
in the United States and we see that in
political dysfunction and in my opinion
we also see it in a slowing of growth
what our or let me rephrase it a
different way are there good examples in
your mind of countries that are over
regulating in a way where development is
being stifled like I don't think the
United States is one of those examples
in fact I think in the United States we
have many problems from lack of
regulation right are there good examples
of what too much regulation looks like
yes
France and particularly France of 20
years ago particularly or Germany 20
years ago
he probably Italy falls in that category
yeah those places have got the balance
slightly wrong and I you know you use
the word regulation I
think we have to add to regulation in
your formulation regulation and things
that equalized incomes in other words if
you make things to equal couple it's
communism you lose the ambition the
ambition innovative creative side of
things and and your economy becomes less
vibrant Sweden is an example I think of
probably a country that has got good
balance these days for Sweden I don't I
don't mean to say that we all have to be
like Swedes or Denmark
but they used to be much more regulatory
much more progressive in their tax and
transfers system and they realize that
their country was losing out in terms of
innovation and creativity and they pull
back on that and now they've got a
better balance we probably went too far
in the other way let's pause the
conversation there this is a good good
place to pause with Stephen Pearlstein
whose recent book is can American
capitalism survive why greed is not good
opportunity is not equal in fairness
won't make up make us poor we will pick
up our conversation with him tomorrow
well we will focus in a little more on
specific economic policies Stephen thank
you great to be with you David we're
continuing our conversation today with
Stephen Pearlstein who's a Business and
Economics columnist at the Washington
Post also Robinson professor of public
affairs at George Mason University in
Fairfax Virginia his recent book is can
American capitalism survive why greed is
not good opportunity is not equal and
fairness won't make us poor Steven maybe
now in part two of the interview we
could focus in on some specific economic
policies just to pick one that's in the
the discussion a lot when we think about
the minimum wage
we often get what I call kind of bad
faith arguments about the minimum wage
ideas of well if more money for people
is good make the minimum wage $200 which
of course nobody that I've heard
seriously consider the issue has
actually suggested how should a society
like the United States an economy like
the United States can
Seve of how to set a minimum wage we
have a number of policies that
accomplish two things equalized income
to some degree but in the case of the
minimum wage I think there's something
else and it appeals to a moral instinct
we all have which is nobody should
should live in deprivation at a in a
rich country so there should be a floor
and the minimum wage is one of several
policies that work together nicely and
you wouldn't want to rely on any one of
them too much one is the minimum wage
one is what we call the Earned Income
Tax Credit which is essentially a wage
supplement for that the government gives
to individuals who work to boost up
their wages and the third is a whole set
of rules that we have that protect
workers from being taken advantage of so
some of these things come after the
market has spoken like the Earned Income
Tax Credit where you get a check back at
the end of the quarter or the end of the
year some of them work beforehand like
the minimum wage or things like says you
you have the right to organize a labor
you knew the threat of which helps to
lower raise the wages for people even
who are not unionized or we have rules
that say you know you can only make
someone work 40 hours a week and after
that you have to pay overtime those are
so what's go under the category of pre
distribution as opposed to
redistribution but they work together to
assure that nobody lives in deprivation
or should live in deprivation
particularly people who work and when it
comes to the specifics of the minimum
wage how should it be set in other words
the minimum wage should be set relative
to what and and you know to
contextualize it we sometimes see
studies about what it costs for a
one-bedroom apartment in particular
cities or states we see comparisons to
the federal poverty level which has you
know it's a whole other can of worms in
terms of how that's calculated how
should we think about what the numbers
should be well we shouldn't think about
it in terms of
what rents are you have to think about
it in terms of when it becomes
self-defeating how when it gets to a
certain level so that businesses behave
in ways that are counterproductive to
the people who are trying to help or to
the economy in the whole and you know
it's a judgement call and as I say you
need to see it in the context of other
things let me just give you an example
with working with the EITC you had a
high minimum wage then the company
essentially pays most of the raising for
most of the raising and the government
contribution goes down whereas if you
have a relative like we do today a low
minimum wage then the EITC tops you up
but you know it's a question of well do
you want to let the businesses off the
hook you could get rid of the minimum
wage and just rely totally on Annie ITC
but that well that would mean is for the
lowest skilled workers the government
would be and that therefore the
taxpayers would be doing the subsidy
whereas if you have a higher minimum
wage the subsidy comes from somewhere
else
who pays the subsidy and a higher
minimum wage let's be clear about it
sometimes shareholders or owners of
company but it's just as likely as
others other employees pay it or
customers pay it and there's nothing
wrong with that but you have to sort of
analyze where you want the subsidy to go
and whether the subsidy gets so high
that it starts to distort economic
behavior in ways that reduce efficiency
you reduce growth reduce the kind of
incentives that you want so it's a
judgment call but I don't think you look
at it I should look at it in terms of
the minimum wage should guarantee that
everybody has a certain standard of
living that's putting too much weight on
that one policy if we think about the
minimum wage and the Earned Income Tax
Credit as a sort of floor or something
meant to lift the bottom yeah what
should we be considering at the other
end of the spectrum what would be how
progressive do you think the tax
brackets should be at what point and to
what degree should we be taxing really
high incomes where are you on sort of
the
top end of the spectrum I'm not with the
there's a sort of Paquette II group and
others who think that we can go to 70%
and 80% I'm not in that group I think
you do Stu stort behaviors I think when
you start getting a lot above and the
Swedes discovered this a lot about 50%
you start getting behaviors you don't
like and the first behavior you get is
you get tax avoidance you get people
moving out of the country you get people
playing games you know a lot of people
like say oh we had tax rates of 90% in
the 1950s and look we had a great
economy well nobody paid 90 percent that
no one was that dumb and 90 percent will
have a bad just as a bad disincentive
effect on on working and investing so
you want to be careful 50 percent
combined with other kinds of things like
getting rid of a lot of loopholes so
that 50 percent is closer to the
effective tax rate rather than just the
marginal rate that's one thing you can
do you certainly want a tax on inherited
wealth we have a lot more to go that we
could tax on that it doesn't really have
bad incentive effects because you know
the guy who's working is dead and the
people who get it it's a windfall for
them so there are other things we can do
to raise money and and and deal with a
bit more redistribution but I want to
emphasize here that I'm in the camp that
thinks we the thing we need to focus on
more than redistribution we do need to
do more of that is pre distribution that
is changing the rules and the norms so
that the distribution of market income
is more fair yeah so that's sort of
where I was going to go next I mean can
you talk about what tools exist to sort
of raise the bottom and potentially
constrain the top a little bit to reduce
that inequality in the pre distributive
phase I mean we're we're talking about
earnings we're talking about some other
sort of earlier in the economic process
mechanism what tools exist in which do
you like well there's a lot of them and
and and
you know they all they all work in
different ways the minimum wages is one
but whether you can whether you can
organize unions and whether that's a
credible threat that has an effective
distribution we on the distribution of
income whether you have trade treaties
free trade treaties or not that affects
the distribution of income whether you
have a financial system that is allowed
to grow to be too large and to skim off
the top too much of the natural national
wealth that's
affects the distribution so does
antitrust policy one of the big things
that people don't understand these days
and this is different than the
inequality of the the 80s and the 90s
today the inequality the biggest driver
of inequality is from people who have
the same skills and do the same job but
what happens to work for Facebook and
the other happens to work for you know
ABC carpet and there's a big growing gap
between people who have the same skills
the same experience the same seniority
so what is that about well that's about
antitrust policy that has has not been
effectively used so that some businesses
and some industries collect collect
rents which is above average profits and
other business at the expense of other
businesses so those are all things that
I think we have to have to consider in
terms of pre distribution you mentioned
Facebook we've seen some of these public
shame campaigns
Rokon a congressman from California who
I've interviewed participated Bernie
Sanders has participated companies like
Amazon and Walmart who have been you
could say shamed convinced whatever
phrase you want to kind of attached to
it into raising the minimum wage that
they would offer to employees what's
your view on that because my analysis of
the Amazon decision was this is
perfectly good for the individual
workers who now get a raise but it's not
actually changing the system and it's
also of pretty significant public
relations benefit to Amazon such that it
might even be an economic boon so I was
praising it as the right decision but at
the same time hesitant to say that these
shame campaigns are the solution well
this is maybe a place David where you
and I are going to disagree I there's
lots of policies that I think we should
change I mentioned some of them yeah but
for me the big change between the 1980s
and today is that norms of behavior
changed and I can tell you that chief
executive officers in the 1950s and 60s
had as much power as they do today but
they never would have paid themselves
and their immediate colleagues what they
pay themselves today and the reason they
wouldn't because it would have been
socially unacceptable and I actually
think changing the norms is more
effective than having lots of government
rules and regulations which can tend to
get corrupted and they get brittle and
inflexible
I'd rather there be a norm in the
business community which is when our
company does well our people do well and
that profit sharing comes naturally and
no one would think not to do it because
if you don't do it you won't get your
customers will leave you you won't be
able to attract and retain good
employees and maybe you won't even be
able to attract long-term capital and I
would much rather focus on changing the
norms then I would in go over doing the
prescription of government rules and
regulations so in other words it's it's
in a way you're saying that if we go
back to what you said earlier about a
lot of times the cost of an increased
minimum wage is sort of borne by the CEO
and others at the top of the food chain
within a company that if you can
convince a company to raise its minimum
wage in effect that has a sort of
limiting influence on the outrageous CEO
pay that we're seeing and you're
accomplishing a lot of good things yeah
in case of minimum wage and CEO pay I
wouldn't put those two things in the
same paragraph but your general point is
that is my general point that you want
to change the norms so that companies
feel that
is both in their interest but also the
right thing to do to share success in
ways that we used to and that are
beneficial in the way they do in
countries like Sweden and and and in
Denmark so we I don't want a rule or a
law that says CEOs can't get paid
anymore than X sure um that we tried we
sort of tried that and it didn't work so
well we and I don't I don't begrudge you
know the truth is I don't begrudge Bill
Gates his billions I don't begrudge most
superstar authors their their millions
but when you have a business which is a
collective enterprise which in which is
very hard to determine and the market is
not perfect to this what everyone's
contribution is you want a system where
we all we all do well when the company
does well and we all do a little bit
badly when the company does badly you
want you want the downside as well as
the upside so what I would do for
example to nudge the world in that
direction is to say it is the government
to say in its tax code if you want to
deduct the expenses of CEO and executive
bonuses or stock options or whatever
that are that are meant to be incentive
pay you can do that but you can only do
it if you have a program where you spend
at least as much money providing similar
incentives to frontline employees then
will allow you to deduct them but if you
don't want to give that to the frontline
employees then you can't deduct the ones
for the executives so that's a way of
using using the government and the rules
to nudge it in behavior but also it's
good to do that in the context of a
changing social norm which says you know
companies that are successful shouldn't
treat their employees badly or squeeze
them for every last dollar that's not a
good way to behave and how do we change
the norms well you you don't change you
change the norms first of all by having
conversations like this but you also
change the norms when investors certain
investors say I'm not going to invest in
companies that don't treat their workers
well or you have customers who say I'm
not going to do business with that you
know one of the things I found about
Amazon was very interesting and around
that time was happy
a lot of my friends were saying I would
say oh you know go buy my book on Amazon
and say what they say I don't do
business with Amazon anymore and I said
really why not
well they don't treat their employees
well I was actually surprised by that so
and and guess what I think that had a
lot of effect on on Amazon's behavior as
did by the way their ability to attract
young and young employees who care a lot
about these things we've been speaking
about at least partially about some of
the topics in the book can American
capitalism survive why greed is not good
opportunity is not equal and fairness
won't make us poor we've been speaking
with the book's author Stephen
Pearlstein thanks so much for talking to
me today
my pleasure dude